Họ hàng tiên Rồi Tân sửa mỗi mọi người bộ của lâu nâm thóc cho thấy
đi đăng thảo luận nhiều phương ám nhằm về xe rế khế một số động mình
à tô. Chúng tôi cạnh mất động liên quan đến việc hỗ trợ
có họ đậm buồn sử của Washington trong cuộc chiến với Iran.
Tại liệu này được cháu là thị hiện sự thức vọng của Mỹ được một số nước
trở ổ như đánh phá là hạn chế quyền tiếp cạnh, sự dụng
căn cứ và không phận cho các họ đậm buồn sửa.
Một tiên dấu kênh cho biết I-mail nếu khả ngăn, đình chỉ
tương cách chính viên của một số cú gia gây khó khăn.
Trong đó, để cập diên tựa tâm nha, gió lập trường không cho phép
sự dụng cạnh cứ để tấn công Iran.
Mọi giá một số phương ám năng tính điều tựa, như điều chiến quan điểm
của Mỹ để cây chính chấp lãnh vổ lịch sự của anh cục lượng nhắc tới.
Nếu vấn ngộ lâu nâm góc, thịng sĩ quý dân nhấn mạnh,
nà tô không thể là cơ trế một châu, đồng thời khẳng định bộ chính trưng
sẽ bảo đạm tổng thống có các lựa trọng phù hợp để bảo vệ lợi ý nghĩ,
chính quyền tế bằng nhà và một số nước liên quan chưa được gia bình luận
chực tiếp về nội dùng email.
Giờ phần thích châu săng tất cả tạo lợi này phản anh căng thẳng
thẳng giá tăng trưng một bộ nà tô, liên quan đến chia sẻ gánh năng ăn nình.
Le bế chương mối cảnh chính sự với Iran tý tụng tất cả động tự ăn nình tòn cầu,
và một định khu vực.